in this series I'm going to surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard craft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
budding Chef I'm going to give you the
confidence that recipes and The Insider
knowledge to make you a much better cook
sliced around
wasting nothing
I made my name cooking some of the
world's most demanding kitchens
in my restaurants I expect Perfection
every play has to be worthy of a
Michelin star and every time you make it
yeah every day changes here now I'm
going to show you some simple and
accessible recipes for fantastic food
that you can cook easily at home
incredible I'll be holding you by the
hand it's getting better and better and
better
she knew everything from how to cook on
a budget to bacon real fast food and my
ultimate feast recipes this is the only
cooking course you'll ever need
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
this is my guide to cooking with spice
adding big gutsy flavors using spices at
the beginning of cooking and then simply
letting the dish slow cook is a
brilliant way of getting maximum flavor
with minimum effort
my first recipe melts in the mouth and
because the oven does most of the work
it's a cinch to make slow cooked fiery
lamb cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it Cooks the more flavor
something it becomes
marinating the lamb first chilies we're
going to use a mixture of red and green
take off the tops
and just slice
in garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just
get it in there cooking for up to three
hours
everything sort of Blends and almost
sort of
pures itself together
smoked paprika it goes brilliantly well
with the chilies two teaspoons thin a
touch of dried oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out is
extraordinary they release a little oil
as well and helps to tenderize the lamb
touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb Chomp in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
a lamb with spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious vegetables carrots and
onions and that's it sliced
cigarette slicing vegetables for
braising is not getting too thin you
slice the onions too thin they burn
you've got that horrible Char taste on
that slow braised braising it's just a
chef's term that means cooking in liquid
on a low heat making the meat incredibly
moist and beautifully tender so the
secret of braising is having a really
nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
Touch of olive oil
lemon hold the bone because you're in
control then into the pan
you want that white fat to start
rendering so it'll add more fat
therefore making it a lot more
flavoursome as it braises
chillers cinnamon
in mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're going
to color on the lamb which washes off as
it braises in the oven so be generous
with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of Baileys
so now you lift the lamb up
and get the lamb
sat on top of the vegetables
now delays the pan with red wine
the glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
it can really transform that dish always
delays then bring it to the boil and
cook for about 10 minutes to reduce the
wines reduced down by half now for the
stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
I slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouth-wateringly tender now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and creamy tender grab it by the
the shank rolling around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce
isn't that beautiful just get some mint
don't chop it just pick that fresh mint
and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting in the mouth lamb
shank amazing
foreign
to get the most out of your spices
there's only one piece of kit that you
need pestle and water I mean they look
fantastic and it's essential for any
good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pestos
to dressings and cost them around 15
quid
used to grind spices and you'll max out
on Flavor get perfect textures and
always be totally in control make sure
you've got a nice large circumference of
the bowl
so you can grind away the heavier the
more durable they are the more
confidence it gives you when you're
pounding and there's almost a way of
confirming homemade hand pounded
grab yourself a pestle and mortar and
soon you'll be spicing with ease
spices are a brilliant way to add an
extra layer and a depth of complexity to
any dish learning to use them properly
will really improve your cooking here
are three more of my super simple spice
recipes to get you going
[Music]
first up a very easy chili and spiced
white bait
start with the spice coating
toast Szechuan peppercorns and coriander
seeds in a hot dry pan to release their
flavors
add chili flakes and grind the pestle
and water to make a fiery fine powder
combined with plain flour season and mix
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
bait are an oily fish they are healthy
delicious and cooking minutes
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
[Music]
ready in under 10 minutes chili and
spiced white bait and easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
start with my take on razal hanud a
classic Moroccan spice blend in a dry
pan toast Cinnamon cloves coriander
fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
add paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus peel and chop butternut
squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped Ginger
fizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allowed to cool and place in a blender
tahini a Nutty paste made from sesame
seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon
juice and a drizzle of olive oil
flits into a luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus
my final deliciously spicy dishes
curry spice sweet corn soup
[Music]
first The Fragrant curry paste
roast coriander and cumin seeds until
aromatic
then grind add in crushed garlic chili
powder turmeric and finely chopped
Ginger
[Music]
bring together with olive oil to form a
thick paste
for the soup fry finely chopped onions
in olive oil
[Music]
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors
add cubed potatoes
chicken stock
and season
when the potato has softened stir in
creamed corn
then add whole sweet corn kernels with
some of the juices
and transfer to a blender and Blitz
until smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
[Music]
is ready to serve
[Music]
wonderfully satisfying curried spice
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch
three more stunning recipes that make
cooking with spice simple
incredible
[Music]
this is my guide to cooking with spice
next up my shopping guide to buying
spices
[Music]
when I buy my spice I only want the best
and it always pays to get expert advice
Burger has been selling every spice
Under the Sun in London's not a hill for
over 20 years so she really knows what
she's talking about I love spices to
smell the text
so versatile something very very simple
can be really transformed into something
really delicious with thousands of
aromatic ingredients on a shelf if it
smells good she sells it if you're
buying spices buy them whole then you
can try roast them grind them when you
need them and then they will release the
essential oils whole spices you can keep
for years give them a good bushing wine
bottle with your rolling pin or whatever
and you see there is still Aroma and you
can taste it you smell it then it's fine
there's four main spouses one is sweet
one is sour one is bitter and one is hot
this is cinnamon and that is really a
great example of a sweet spice when you
buy cinnamon quill like this you have to
check that you have loads of different
layers in here then you can either grind
this or you'd break a piece off I mean
this doesn't smell of anything now
but if you roll it in your hand just
quickly like this
and then you smell it again this is just
unbelievable if you have spaghetti
bolognese put a pinch of cinnamon in it
to bring out the flavor
this is one of those
really special spices sour like a lemon
but it has a salty aftertaste I use this
anywhere for marinades to salad you
haven't lived unless you tried it a
great example for a bitter spice would
actually be a turmeric this is actually
a root it grows in the ground like
ginger use it very very sparingly about
that much well actually color you a
curry or a rice dish wonderful yellow
watch your fingers you get really yellow
fingers from it and then we come to the
hot spices one spice that I couldn't
miss and that is Hungarian paprika
paprika is the powdery form of a bell
pepper what makes the Hungarian paprika
different is that they actually cried on
Vineyards it's sort of between the vines
it has a sweetness and it has a
sharpness to it I have it in ice cream I
have it on fish I have it everywhere
burger spot on about the power of spices
to transform dishes where there's Savory
or sweet here's my quick guide to the
spices I use most
spice I couldn't do without always buy a
hole and grind yourself so you get the
freshest flavor cardamom these pods come
in green or black types and have a
fantastic Spicy Sweet Taste brilliant
for everything from curries to rice
dishes and puddings
coriander these citrusy seeds are
perfect whole in pickles or grind to use
in fragrant stews and soups
cumin a Savory Spice that's pungent and
nutty it's great in marinade for
delicious Meat and Fish
then cinnamon sweetly fragrant and great
with apples or in cakes
and Nutmeg warm and spicy it's delicious
in a vegetable sauce finely saffron
these sweet strands Infuse a brilliant
bright red color and are great in
risottos and even though it's more
expensive than gold a pinch goes a long
long way store your spices properly and
they'll last for years you keep it
airtight in a tin or in a glass chair in
your cupboard
don't be scared of spices like an
aftershave or a perfume you have to
select it yourself it has to fit in with
your taste and with your kitchen
supermarkets and good local shops sell
an amazing array of different spices so
there's no excuse for not being
adventurous be bold find what you like
and spice up your cooking
like all chefs I love the challenge of
transforming classic recipes giving them
a new twist to make them modern and
vibrant
to keep old dishes fresh and exciting
it's great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored British
classic but with addition of spices it
gives a new lease of Life fragrant spice
rice pudding I love cooking with spices
but you don't have to just cook Savory
dishes using aromatics and spices across
desserts takes your puddings to a
completely different level
[Music]
first off our spices this is a fresh
vanilla pot fragrant and packed full of
flavor use the back of the knife and
flatten it that removes all those little
seeds off the skin of the vanilla pod
take your knife slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible take the tip of the knife
and you scrape inside and look
at all those seeds dying to come out
that is incredible there are thousands
of seeds still ingrained to the Pod so
put them in to the casserole cardamom
powerful spicy
take two little pods place your knife on
top
lightly crack them cracking the cardamom
pods helps release all the amazing
flavor cloves because of that kind of
aniseed flavor with a lot of depth
one two three cinnamon stick
snap and in
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding is
in the taste of turn on the heat lightly
toast those spices just a couple of
seconds and what's going to happen is
just going to sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
an even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk in
sugar
two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavors to infuse and this rice pudding
reminds me of my time in India where I
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious and so
comforting
take a lime
in the lime just cuts through the
richness of the coconut gives it that
nice little bit of acidity goes
fantastically well with the cinnamon and
that fresh vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and then with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out for
three to five minutes
bullying it rapidly the rice opens up
and it goes into mush I want to keep
that nice texture of that sort of
fragrant rice pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
I'm going to show you how I take this
simple delicious aromatic rice pudding
to a completely different level here's
what I do take
two egg yolks separating them
and give that a really nice whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
we started into the egg yolks
so it's nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard turn off
the gas add that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked started to
go nice and soft you can just see how
it's opening up
but looks like Rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally Great Mall Citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
a rice pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200 degrees to finish cooking the
rice and develop the intensely aromatic
flavors
look at that
an incredibly fragrant rice pudding how
beautiful does that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
I'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
next my trick is the trays and kitchen
tips
first how to zest the lemon
the important part is not to zest any of
the pith watch the following technique
and I'll show you how
we've got these original graters really
important when we use this this is the
fine zester not the big rough one not
the one for slicing and not the other
one for grating this little one here
onto a plate because it's always easier
to lift off from the plate than it is
the board and the most important thing
about zesting a lemon is nice long
strokes but twisting the lemon round
every time we go down we twist
same with the orange and same with the
lime
tap
if you go too far
let me just show you look you've got
that white bitter pith that destroys the
wonderful zesty flavor and look that's
what we're looking for there this really
nice vibrant lemon zest delicious
garlic is a key ingredient in so many
spicy dishes my tip for finely chopping
and mincing is add a pinch of salt for
abrasion which helps break the fibers of
the garlic down for a much better result
but getting the most out of root Ginger
simply remove the skin using a teaspoon
it's easier than using a knife and you
can get around the tricky bits or just
keep the skin on and give it a good wash
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavor left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge
when grinding up spices if you have any
left over you can store in an airtight
jar for up to two months great for a
spicy kick to have at your fingertips
foreign
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
tips
and 100 recipes to stay your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better Chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the app store for details
go on get cooking
with cooking tips information and 100
recipes to stay your life on take it
easy because it's time for my ultimate
slow cooking
[Music]
slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chess Arsenal not only is it easy
it's also an incredible way to transform
meat into mouth-wateringly melting
dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow-cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it Cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones across there
and as the short rib Cooks it sticks to
that bone the bone implants flavor and
the meat just sort of melts Cooks slowly
gives it that nice level intensity slice
alongside the bone straight down and see
that marbling that sort of disappears
and disintegrates I'm cooking them in a
roasting tray get it on the heat until
nice and hot
season beef short ribs beautifully
olive oil in both of the top we'll start
coloring that in
[Music]
really important to give the big short
ribs a really nice Sear
if you didn't Brown the meat off it goes
in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that nice dark Rich coloring
cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the sauce stir in a heap
teaspoon of tomato puree I'm just
hitting the bottom of the pan
without tomato puree
and we call it cooking house the tomato
puree otherwise it just goes in there
raw and it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs red
wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this Burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor it makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark Rich intensity
look at my garlic that is just gonna
sweeten everything up incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
I can all that flavor as the beef ribs
slow cook cover them so they braise from
the bottom and steam from the top into
the oven two and a half hours
170 to 180 degrees
and she goes
the great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish this is light cured
pancetta
I want nice thick lardons
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
these are delicious Chestnut mushrooms
I'm not going to slice them
just going to cut them in half
look at the color on those loud ones now
all the white raw fat have disappeared
the larvans have shrunk right down and
all we've got there now is the proper
bacon mushrooms in
beautifully so the mushrooms get
seasoned from the bacon I'm pan frying
these separately to the beef so they're
main crisp another different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down now this is like
Christmas day for me when you unwrap
that fall wait to see what's underneath
it
[Music]
hmm
wow
smell
incredible
lift
in place
on your tray
beautiful
to make a fantastic Rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices
we're all that nice pureed garlic coming
through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing flavor
scrape all that off the sieve
nice
then just start
saving all that lovely braising liquor
whoa
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
to Boone on your bacon and your
mushrooms
[Music]
beautiful
be generous with these mushrooms I'm
telling you they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley on that freshness over
those amazing ribs incredible never ever
be embarrassed about going to your
Butcher and asking for cheap Cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs with bacon and mushrooms
mushrooms are one of my all-time
favorite ingredients
I use Chestnut mushrooms with the beef
short ribs because all of their firm
texture and nutty taste but there's a
huge range of other mushrooms that are
great for slow cooked dishes
and when it comes to buying them there's
one expert green grocer who's a Fountain
of Knowledge Burma Marcus Fred Foster
started off on the dead store in primary
coat really you get a salad stall with
over 20 years of experience you could
actually write his own mushroom
encyclopedia
mushrooms as soon as you pick them the
moisture starts coming out of them so
you need to buy them when they're fresh
certain products you smell for flavor
and they tend to be fruits mushrooms
don't smell nice at all they smell kind
of metallic really
so you have to use your eyes as your
guide of what you buy with mushrooms
really really important wild mushrooms
are literally grown wild in the forests
they're just quality wherever they are
this is morel mushroom
a fantastic products so hard to find in
the world it's almost got an apricot
type of flavor earthy Woody and of
course as you cook it the flavor
increases for extra flavor and texture
highly prized morels are ideal when
added to slow cooked stews and
casseroles as are the trumpet de lemur
which have a deliciously rich flavor
another wild type to try is the
chanterelle its subtle fruity flavor is
delicious and perfect fried with butter
parsley and garlic when you're dealing
with wild mushrooms you need to clean
them it can be quite a slow process it's
with a soft brush don't don't use water
never use water with mushrooms it
deteriorates the mushroom rapidly oyster
mushrooms are very meaty mushroom just a
lovely silky smooth flavor really nice
how do you tell whether it's fresh those
gills are bright never cut a noise the
mushroom always tear it look at the
whiteness of that beautiful that would
be great if it was old although also
found wild oyster mushrooms are more
commonly cultivated along with similar
type the Enoki their delicate taste is
grain salads and soups
finally Fred saved the best until last
and of course the Pinnacle is the
Truffle they are really really short
after the smell is so intense that smell
it's it's hard to describe because it's
such a unique smell the more expensive
the Truffle the more intense the smell
so that's why you use such a small
amount on a dish it's amazing the way
they get these they used to use pigs of
course but they don't do that anymore
they use Dog Steel because the pigs used
to eat them all this magical tasting
fungi is by weight one of the most
expensive Foods in the world it's
phenomenal eating raw shaves over pasta
or risottos or drizzle of truffle all
Turns Slow cooked stews into something
out of this world people are actually
scared of mushrooms aren't they so it's
amazing really they shouldn't be because
take away the fear and just close your
eyes and taste them they're just amazing
they're they are amazing
[Music]
cooking all the ingredients in one dish
helps to lock in taste and get great
flavors working together here are three
recipes that turn simple ingredients
into amazing dishes
first up a fantastically aromatic
melt-in-the-mouth treat pork neck curry
with mango salsa
[Music]
for the curry paste add chopped
lemongrass chili fresh ginger
garlic and caffeine Lime Leaf to a
pestle and mortar
next put in aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander
pinch of salt black pepper
[Music]
and Bash it into a rough paste
finally add olive oil to loosen and your
paste is done now onto the pork Meg add
a dug of olive oil to a hot pan and
brown the diced meat carefully
making sure each side hits the heat
locking in that flavor
remove and in the same pan cook sliced
onions until Brown around the edges
at the curry paste and Fry to release
all the intense flavors
then put the pork back in along with the
coconut milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar
more kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and
fish sauce to taste
then simply simmer for an hour
[Music]
slow cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful served with
fresh mango salsa pork neck Curry
foreign
recipe is
incredible spicy Szechuan chicken thighs
[Music]
first marinade the thighs with soy sauce
and shouting wine which is made from
fermented rice and tastes similar to dry
sherry
chicken thighs do a lot of work so they
need more cooking but cook properly
they're moist and they're the tastiest
part of the bird next add rice vinegar
water then season and leave to marinade
for up to two hours
then chop garlic
chili and Ginger
add olive oil to a hot pan and fry it
will softened add Szechuan peppercorns
and orange dust
next add the marinated chicken thighs
along with a marinade
and throw in a pinch of sugar and Fry
the chicken until it's lovely and brown
and the sauce is deliciously thick
[Music]
finish with chopped spring onions add
lug of soy sauce and a few drops of
sesame seed oil
marinated for flavor sweet and spicy
chicken a fuss-free Wonder
[Music]
my final slow cooked dish that
transforms simple ingredients into
Unforgettable food is simple beef
brisket
[Music]
start by seasoning the meat well
brisket is a cut of beef from the breast
it's inexpensive but it's fit for raw
tea with long slow cooking
place it into hot casserole dish with a
little olive oil and brown on all sides
[Music]
next make a tasty broth to flavor the
meat into the dish add chopped carrots
celery a whole bulb of garlic cut in
half peppercorns
aromatic cloves and freshly ground
nutmeg
pour in hot water to braise the brisket
bring to the boil and cover tightly then
transfer the dish to a low oven and cook
for three to four hours cook low and
slow the results are amazing tender
melt-in-the-mouth meat
fantastic with roast potatoes or in
sandwiches with lots of mustard but I
like it best with Tangy piccolilly
in the oven in under 10 minutes then all
you have to do is sit back and wait so
easy and absolutely delicious what's not
to love about my succulent beef brisket
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stay your life on soon I'll
be teaching you a wonderful slow cooked
dessert and look at the color on them
these smell
incredible
but first five more of my 100 tips to
make your home cooking easier
[Applause]
foreign
starting with how to cook duck breasts
perfectly the slow way
duck breasts never be scared about
cooking this bird absolutely delicious
very healthy first oven on 200 degrees
and then
salt pepper
now the salt will help to extract the
water out of the fat
nonstick pan no oil but start the duck
breasts in the pan cold
skin side down it feels and sounds a
little bit weird but if we put them into
a cold pan and turn the heat up
gradually it starts to release the fat
if we put them into a hot pan
it seals them in and the fat stays in
there we want to render that fat down 90
of that duck breast will be cooked on
its skin keeps the duck nice and moist
but more importantly it stays crispy
once the fat comes out turn the duck
over
nice high hot heat
seal the duck now they're going in the
oven skin side down 200 six to eight
minutes
if your Pan's got a plastic handle out
then transfer the duck breast onto a
tray but make sure you put the tray into
the oven to get hot first
cooking duck is like cooking a piece of
beef and you can't slice it piping hot
all the goodness Runs Out just quickly
turn it over
push your fingers in there and it's
slightly resistant but still quite
bouncy and that confirms they're quite
pink in the center but the important
part now is leaving that to rest let
them cool down
and then we'll slice them
keep that excess duck fats and there you
go next time you start taking potatoes
you just take them to a completely
different level now slicing the dirt
just slice at an angle not too thin if
you slice it thinner it goes cold
quickly so nice thick slices
nice crispy skin on top
and a beautiful Clump roasted dark all
the white fat gone nice crispy skin and
absolutely delicious
another slow cooking tip is when slow
cooking stews and casseroles fat will
rise to the surface to get rid of any
excess oils my tip is to remove them
with kitchen paper before serving
this also works brilliantly on gravies
and sauces
many great slow cook dishes start by
Browning the meat as the meat Cooks lots
of flavors get stuck to the pan to get
it into your sauce deglaze with wine
stock or vinegar
never add soft herbs at the beginning of
slow cooking they're all too delicate
the tip is to add them at the end for
that Hill fresh flavor and vibrant color
a great tip when frying fish is to
always fry skin side down to keep it
crispy
and always lay the foods away from you
when adding to the pan to prevent hot
oil from splashing towards you
[Music]
foreign
cooking isn't exclusive to just Savory
dishes it's a clever way to transform
fruit into wonderful desserts giving
them an amazing sticky Jammy intensity
invest a bit of patience and my next
recipe pays off big time
Indulgence and bursting with flavor
caramelized figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful Rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green figs because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious lay your figs out in a rows
take some Rosemary and just peel that
down look at that really nice fragrant
stem get your scissors trim the edge
almost we've got a bit of a sort of
sharp Point bring your three figs
together
just thread the top of each fig
nice and gently Rosemary works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stock will
impart a lovely subtle flavor useful
dust the figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of Blossom
with vinegar leave them to sit there for
five minutes they sort of marinade I
know it sounds odd to use vinegar in
your dessert but trust me it gives the
dish a fantastic sweet and sour taste
I'm gonna make a really nice caramel
four or five tablespoons of sugar now
flatten that out and get it nice and
even when the sugar is even caramel
Cooks evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in the one thing you
don't do is shake the pan rapidly
and sit almost like sort of a lake
defrosting and it's hitting to the
center it's bubbling it's still not dark
enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas another butter in
there
gently whisking
the butter is cooling the camel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe Olay
next add a dug of the balsamic vinegar
beautiful
for that nice dark richness
of a camel a little touch of water in
there
that way the camel doesn't go too thick
now put the camel back on the heat take
a fix and sort of place them in gently
lovely
and then just added all that lovely
little marinade
don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
icing sugar and butter vinegar
so tasty
based those figs because the skin gets
nice and crispy on the outside and the
Fig sort of just absorbs the caramel
delicious so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
they smell
is incredible
onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that camera
now douse the figs with caramel
and served with ricotta cheese the
freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
I'm gonna finish that now
see a zest
and then some little nibbed almonds
and the rich creamy Jam texture of the
Fig
with a ricotta
brilliant that is an amazing way of slow
roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]
cookery course crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stag your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking